Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Sono qui, oggi, per presentarvi
un'idea innovativa
che speriamo possa costituire
una risposta concreta
ad una delle più grandi sfide
che il nostro mondo
si trova ad affrontare:
la sfida dell'energia.
L'idea ha un nome, Kite Energy,
e nasce coniugando due aspetti:
uno più leggero, se vogliamo, e ludico;
e un aspetto più serio e scientifico.
Partiamo da quest'ultimo,
quello più serio e scientifico:
essendo un ingegnere, ho un po'
questa deformazione professionale.
Il nostro mondo sta cambiando
molto in fretta, molto rapidamente,
soprattutto negli ultimi decenni.
La popolazione mondiale
sta crescendo in maniera esponenziale;
è notizia di qualche giorni addietro
che è nata la bambina sette miliardi,
il settemiliardesimo membro
di questa affollata navicella
che è la Terra.
Si prevede che nel 2045
saremo nove miliardi
e nel 2100 si toccherà quota 15 miliardi.
Pensate, in meno di 100 anni
la popolazione mondiale sarà raddoppiata.
La richiesta di energia
continua ad aumentare e non conosce crisi,
in particolare in quei paesi che un tempo
venivano anche chiamati "paesi emergenti",
e che oggi sono sulla cresta dell'onda.
In quei paesi,
le popolazioni e le persone
richiedono sempre più energia
per i loro usi, per i loro consumi,
per i loro prodotti.
Gli usi sono i più svariati;
dall'utilizzo di dispositivi
e apparecchiature per la vita quotidiana,
a energia per la creazione
e la realizzazione
di questi beni di consumo,
energia per la mobilità.
Quindi, sempre maggiore
richiesta di energia
significa maggiore sfruttamento
delle fonti energetiche.
Se l'energia fosse
infinitamente disponibile,
il problema forse non si porrebbe,
o si porrebbe soltanto in parte.
In realtà non è così:
l'energia non è infinitamente disponibile,
e soprattutto noi facciamo uso
di fonti energetiche
che sono di derivazione fossile,
tipicamente il carbone,
il petrolio, il gas;
e utilizziamo queste fonti energetiche,
queste fonti fossili
a dei ritmi che non ne consentono
il naturale rinnovamento.
Quindi, queste fonti
sono in via di esaurimento.
Il problema è anche che gran parte
dei giacimenti di queste fonti
sono concentrate
in alcuni paesi, pochi paesi,
e da ciò ne consegue un'incertezza
nell'offerta di queste fonti,
una forte volatilità dei prezzi
e soprattutto, anche,
degli squilibri geopolitici
che spesso degenerano
in tensioni internazionali e in guerre.
E non è finita qui,
perché l'utilizzo di queste fonti fossili
comporta anche l'emissione
di sostanze inquinanti
che hanno degli effetti a livello locale,
a livello regionale, a livello globale.
Tra queste sostanze
vi è l'anidride carbonica, la CO2,
che molti scienziati ritengono essere
una delle cause principali
del riscaldamento globale
in atto nel nostro pianeta.
Questi scienziati hanno dimostrato
che c'è una correlazione
tra le temperature sul nostro pianeta
e i livelli di emissione della CO2,
i livelli di concentrazione
di CO2 nell'atmosfera.
Sebbene ci sia molto dibattito
intorno a questo tema,
un aspetto, una cosa è inconfutabile:
i livelli di emissione di CO2
sono cresciuti vertiginosamente
negli ultimi decenni,
alterando in maniera significativa
la composizione naturale
chimica dell'atmosfera.
Bene, dopo questi scenari
un po' inquietanti,
ma non ci dobbiamo fare spaventare,
passiamo all'aspetto invece più ludico
che ci fa guardare al futuro con fiducia.
Molti mi chiedono
com'è nata questa innovazione.
Come molte innovazioni nasce da un'ideale,
un'ideale di vita e da un'intuizione.
L'ideale di vita è quello di poter vivere
in un mondo che possa progredire,
tutelando al contempo quell'enorme dono
che è rappresentato dalla natura
nel suo complesso.
Quindi l'ideale è quello, proprio
di fare un buon uso del mondo,
come lo slogan di questo evento.
L'intuizione deriva dalla contemplazione
della natura stessa.
Natura che ci dà tante cose,
direi quasi tutte le cose
di cui l'uomo ha bisogno
per vivere su questo pianeta.
Tra queste cose c'è anche l'energia:
l'energia del sole, l'energia del vento,
l'energia dell'acqua.
Spesso noi utilizziamo questa energia
come svago, come divertimento,
per far volare
degli aquiloni, per esempio.
Personalmente questo aspetto ludico
mi ha permesso di avvicinare l'intuizione,
essendo io un grande appassionato
di sport all'aperto,
in particolare di sport velici.
Però c'è anche da dire
che l'energia della natura
è sempre stata utilizzata dall'uomo,
nei secoli, nei millenni -
non l'ho certo scoperta io
andando in windsurf.
È stata utilizzata per il trasporto,
è stata utilizzata per la produzione,
è stata utilizzata anche come arma.
Con l'avvento della
Rivoluzione Industriale, però,
molti paesi hanno puntato
in maniera decisa
su alcune fonti che consentivano
un rapido e massiccio utilizzo
di quelle tecnologie
che erano state sviluppate.
Queste fonti erano le fonti fossili,
le fonti fossili
che tutt'ora ci accompagnano
durante la nostra quotidianità.
E allora il vero punto di svolta,
nel validare questa intuizione,
è stato quello di porsi una domanda:
possono le fonti rinnovabili,
costituire una vera alternativa
alle fonti fossili
per produrre quell'energia
di cui il genere umano è affamato?
[Musica] The answer, my friend,
is blowing in the wind.
"The answer is blowing in the wind"
La risposta è nascosta nel vento,
sibila nel vento;
il vento come fonte di energia.
Questa è stata la risposta immediata
che ha permesso, poi,
di approfondire a livello scientifico,
a livello tecnico l'intuizione.
Il vento è sempre stato,
come abbiamo detto prima,
utilizzato durante i secoli dall'uomo:
e allora perché non è utilizzato
come le fonti fossili attualmente in uso?
Forse perchè la disponibilità di energia
estraibile dal vento è limitata?
In realtà no, la disponibilità
di energia è enorme.
Pensate che è 250 volte superiore
rispetto al fabbisogno
energetico dell'umanità .
Certo, l'energia del vento
è intermittente,
come molte fonti di energia rinnovabile.
Però anche all'intermittenza
si può ovviare,
e le quantità di energia sono molto ampie.
Quindi, dov'è che ci sono
le maggiori quantità di energia?
Beh, per quanto concerne il vento,
più si va in alto
più l'energia disponibile aumenta.
Pensate che a 800 metri di altezza
l'energia estraibile dal vento
è ben quattro volte superiore
rispetto a 100 metri di altezza
rispetto al suolo.
A 100 metri è dove operano
le torri eoliche tradizionali.
Inoltre, a quelle altezze,
il vento è anche più costante
perché diminuisce l'attrito
con l'orografia del terreno -
è l'attrito con l'orografia del terreno
che rallenta i flussi di aria
e che li rende turbolenti.
Quindi è lassù che bisogna andare
per accedere ai giacimenti più appetibili,
ai giacimenti di vento più appetibili.
Con le tecnologie attuali,
non è possibile arrivare a quelle altezze
perché hanno dei limiti tecnologici,
dimensionali, di costo.
Per arrivare a quelle altezze,
è necessario un cambiamento
radicale di prospettiva:
non più macchine pesanti e statiche,
come le torri eoliche attualmente in uso,
ma macchine leggere,
dinamiche e intelligenti.
Anche in questo caso
abbiamo dovuto fare un passaggio
dall'aspetto ludico
all'aspetto scientifico-ingegneristico,
per realizzare il cuore della tecnologia.
È costituito da un profilo alare,
un kite, dotato di sensori di bordo
che trasmettono in tempo reale
le condizioni del kite, le velocità,
a un sistema di controllo che sta a terra.
Da dei cavi ad altissima tecnologia,
in fibra sintetica,
che hanno una resistenza alla trazione
di molto superiore all'acciaio
a parità di peso.
E da un sistema
di controllo dei generatori
che sono posizionati a terra.
L'energia viene prodotta
sfruttando le forze esercitate dai kite,
le forze di trazione
esercitate dai kite sui cavi,
cavi che sono avvolti su dei winch.
Questi winch vengono messi in rotazione
da queste forze di trazione
e sono collegati a loro volta
a dei generatori
dove viene prodotta l'energia elettrica.
Una volta che abbiamo svolto
totalmente i cavi
dobbiamo recuperare i cavi e l'aquilone.
Si fa portando il kite
in una posizione di stallo
e fornendo una piccola parte
dell'energia precedentemente prodotta.
Funziona come una dinamo,
noi la chiamiamo
una "configurazione yo-yo".
Attraverso questi cicli di generazione
è possibile produrre
grandi quantità di energia.
La cosa interessante
è che oltre a studiare
questo sistema, e analizzarlo,
lo abbiamo anche realizzato.
Con il supporto della Regione Piemonte
e in collaborazione
con il Politecnico di Torino
siamo stati i primi al mondo a realizzare
un generatore eolico d'alta quota.
L'abbiamo realizzato e l'abbiamo testato
per centinaia di ore,
in condizioni meteo
e climatiche anche diverse,
in località e localizzazioni diverse,
quindi con test sia a terra, on shore,
che in mare, per verificare
l'applicabilità off-shore.
Devo dire che è stato
anche molto divertente, in alcuni casi.
I risultati sono stati eccellenti,
hanno consentito di confermare
che il concetto funziona -
e non solo funziona.
Validando gli studi teorici
e validando anche
le simulazioni fatte al computer,
abbiamo potuto verificare
che con questa tecnologia
è possibile produrre energia
a costi molto competitivi,
addirittura inferiori
rispetto alle fonti fossili.
E lo si può fare occupando
molto meno territorio
rispetto alle tecnologie
rinnovabili attuali,
come l'eolico tradizionale.
Quindi, attraverso
la tecnologia kitenergy,
è possibile superare quei limiti
delle tecnologie rinnovabili attuali
che hanno rallentato l'adozione
di fonti alternative
in questi ultimi decenni.
Come ho detto prima,
siamo stati tra i pionieri al mondo
ad analizzare, a fare ricerca e sviluppo
su queste tecnologie,
e abbiamo fatto scuola:
negli ultimi anni sono nate molte società
negli Stati Uniti, in Canada,
in Europa, in particolare
in Olanda e in Germania,
addirittura in Cina
dove sono appunto stato recentemente.
La cosa non può che farci piacere
perché significa che la tecnologia
è molto promettente;
dall'altro lato, ci stimola
ancora di più ad andare avanti
per cercare di mantenere questa posizione
di leadership sul mercato.
Per fare questo, però,
ci sono delle difficoltà:
non è tutto facile,
soprattutto nel contesto attuale,
nel contesto economico attuale.
Per sviluppare questa tecnologia
sono necessari forti investimenti,
e il reperimento di finanziamenti
non è facile in questo momento,
soprattutto in Italia.
Ci sono altri paesi, come gli Stati Uniti,
dove i contesti sono sicuramente
molto più favorevoli.
Però, detto questo, andiamo avanti,
andiamo avanti con grande entusiasmo,
con grande determinazione,
abbiamo anche dei piani ambiziosi;
in particolare,
adesso stiamo costruendo
una nuova macchina,
una macchina aggiornata,
migliorata ulteriormente,
che testeremo nel 2012.
Speriamo di portare
a livello commerciale questa tecnologia
a valle di queste sperimentazioni.
Speriamo anche di poter realizzare presto,
in tempi non troppo lunghi,
una wind farm,
un'applicazione industriale
della tecnologia kitenergy.
La sfida dell'energia
si gioca lassù, nel cielo,
e bisogna andare però molto in alto
per superare i limiti
delle tecnologie rinnovabili attuali.
Con KITEnrg,
speriamo di riuscire a dare
un contributo significativo
per vincere questa grande sfida,
una sfida importante e fondamentale
per il futuro del nostro mondo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)